there is a door in the demon souls
remake that did not
exist in the original it's in 1-3
at the opposite end of the courtyard and
suspiciously hidden
at the end of an alleyway behind an
illusory wall
and it appears to be locked
and bluepoint have done something like
this before in their shadow of the
colossus remake they created this locked
door which was actually
a reference to a 10 year old quest that
fans had been going through
in the original game to unlock a
supposed secret area of the game
except now in the remake that locked
door could actually be
opened collect 79 coins hidden in the
enormous world
marking 79 steps to enlightenment and
the door would finally open
revealing a throne room and the sword of
dorman so let's call this the door of
enlightenment
if you use photo mode you can actually
get a glimpse behind it and if you go
into the adjacent alleyway and use photo
mode you can actually see right into the
opposite
side for some people here there's an
item on a corpse
sitting on a bench and for others like
me there's nothing there which
seems to indicate that there is a
condition that needs to be met for this
item to appear
so right now i feel like our best clue
would be figuring out what gets this
item to spawn
and if we can carefully figure out what
that is then maybe we can figure out how
to open the door as well
there are hundreds of thousands of minds
watching this video so it's time
for the five of you who actually own a
ps5 to get to work
while so much of the demon souls remake
is the same as the original
there are things like this in the game
that will surprise you so subscribe
check out the new displate at the end of
the video and enjoy
in demon souls there's a mechanic called
world tendency where your actions can
affect the white or black tendency
of your world making it easier or harder
respectively
and in the original you had to really
squint at these arch stones in the menu
to try and
figure out what level of white or black
world tendency you're in
but now in the remake there's a brand
new world tendency menu
that you're also gonna have to squint at
to try and figure out
what your world tendency is it's not
that easy here either
but what i found curious on this page
was the inclusion of the sixth broken
arch stone
it's almost as if it's positioned and
ready to have its own world tendency
which
also means it could be positioned and
ready for dlc
now you can argue that the original game
also had the sixth broken arch stone on
it but
man i can't help but hope blue point
basically reverse engineered
the entirety of the original demon souls
to create this game
so can you imagine what they could do if
they actually partnered with from
software on
official new dlc content for this game
i really hope that happens so speaking
of fractured things like the broken
archstone
you can now offer 25 000 souls to the
central statue in the nexus
and if you do this you'll unlock three
new quality of life options
which each require more souls to use so
the first is to request forgiveness
and this is basically absolving your
sins in dark souls where
angered npcs can go back to being
neutral this was
actually super useful for me when i
unintentionally unleashed the wrath of
god in the nexus
and obliterated baldwin the second
option is fractured mode which
man it makes my brain fractured i'll
tell you that the fraction mode flips
the entire game horizontally
including your character which really
threw me for a loop considering
you still attack with r1 and block with
l1 so this is supposed to be a way for
the entire game to feel
unique and unfamiliar for veteran
players and
it does definitely achieve that it just
does so at the expense of your sanity
the third option allows you to go back
to the character selection screen
and amend your character's visuals which
is definitely appreciated
but this actually has gameplay
implications as well because in demon
souls there are some armors that you can
only wear on a male character and some
that you can only wear on a female
character so being able to go back and
change to type a or type b
stops you from getting locked out from
certain armor choices on a character
and further up in the nexus there's also
an altar where you can check on your
character profile
one of the only level changes that
bluepoint has made to the game is in 1-4
which is the final stage of the game
unlockable from behind is a door to the
tower which then
allows you to skip the run past the
first section of the bridge
and allows you to go straight up to the
dragon's second roost instead
by which point you're actually so far
ahead that you can just run right past
him
i had to look this up to remember if
this shortcut actually existed in the
original
and the funny thing is when you do
you're hit with these 10 year old posts
from people saying
no shortcut in 1-4 really it's pretty
funny to think that these people finally
got their wish
or maybe they became a blue point
developer and finally made their dream
a reality so here's what you got if you
pre-ordered the game
the reaper's scythe a fancy weapon with
a pole arm moveset
and if you bought the digital deluxe
edition for 20 extra
you would have also received the ritual
blade which has a great axe moveset
and the hoplite shield which is a sort
of large shield
along with two unique armor sets a ring
that increases item discovery
another that increases your health and a
handful of consumables
the armor and the weapons appear to be
true exclusives
and the weapons seem pretty powerful the
ritual blade especially is unique
because it's a great axe-class weapon
that only requires 12 strength which is
a piddly amount compared to the minimums
of its counterparts
and no you can't drop these items online
for other players if you were wondering
but here's the thing these weapons can't
be upgraded either
they're forever stuck at plus zero which
means they're not actually viable beyond
the early game and they will never
really give you an advantage in pvp
i guess this was blue point's solution
to the backlash that would have been
received if these ended up being a
distinct pvp advantage
for people that paid more money and
don't get me wrong i'm glad that it's
like this
but it still doesn't solve the entire
problem you still don't get access to
everything in the game unless you
pre-order the digital deluxe edition
and the new armors are still unique and
nice and you'll never get those
but whatever at least there were unique
items still added to the game
outside of the digital deluxe edition
for example
there's the blue eye knight set there's
the official set
and you now need to collect every piece
of this set to rescue yuria
and not just the hat like in the
original there's the sodden ring
which allows you to move more easily in
the swamp there's the gold coin which is
a rare drop from the officials
and it improves your luck and there's
also the ring of uneven scales which you
get from trading the gold coin to
snuggly
this raises your maximum item burden but
lowers your maximum equipment burden
which
seems like it's the wrong way around
because why would i need more item
burden when i can just
send my items to stockpile thomas but
it's not only the gold coin that snuggly
accepts now
she'll also accept your rune shield for
a 20
hoplite shield and your rune sword for
40 white arrows
and funniest of all is to trade pure
bladestone the rarest drop in the game
for the ring of longevity dlc ring which
raises your maximum health
if there's other trades here then
they're yet to be discovered
and with more items comes more lore and
it's nothing groundbreaking nor should
it be considered canon
but it is still interesting now the
hoplite shield for example
is described as a medium-sized metal
shield designed for boletarian legions
the legion's protective formation was
renowned across the kingdom the blue eye
knight armor was supposedly made with
hardened iron from stonefang
and emblazoned with the image of the sun
as proof of their commission from the
king
the ritual blade mentions the ancient
tribe of the shrine of storms
and the set of the fat officials is said
to serve as a hateful reminder
to the resentful masses also interesting
are the new stage names which
actually didn't exist in the original
and there are also new translations in
the game
that had an opportunity to fix some of
the bad translations
from the original but we'll get to that
in another video you can also warp to
stages that you haven't completed yet
with a press of the ps5 button
which is actually pretty useful
sometimes if you're not near an arch
stone
you will have to give up all your souls
to do this but often you don't care
about that
when you are at an artstone though you
can actually warp to different worlds
with your controller triggers now
in the original you had to go back to
the nexus so this is good
and while you're in the ps5 menu you
should definitely browse the trophy list
which
actually includes some really fun ones
this time around for example
vanquish the tower knight without
killing any archers vanquish made in
australia without killing gal vinland
vanquish adjudicator without having him
fall over
vanquish the fool's idol without hitting
any clones that's a great one
cross the walkway through the idol's
volley of arrows
vanquish penetrator with bjor and
vanquish the dragon god with the hands
of god which i love because
this weapon was said to belong to an
ancient hero who slaughtered dragons
with his bare hands so these are
excellent additions to the game because
they encourage you to play in different
ways and that's something we've kind of
lost ever since from software stopped
adding tail weapons to their games
so i would love to see more things like
this in the future it's great for
replayability
in your options menu they've also added
a great tips page with some clean little
animations
these sorts of animations are also used
when you browse the spell list at
certain vendors allowing you to preview
what you're about
to invest in and if you ever need to
take a breather while playing the
options menu doesn't pause the game but
the photo mode does
just be aware that it doesn't pause the
game if you're playing online
but it does turn the camera into a sort
of free cam instead which
you know is a really great way to
observe your summons while they beat the
game for you and for all intents and
purposes
healing remains the same in the demon
souls remake except instead of being
able to carry 99 of each grass like in
the original
there's now a limit on each type of
grass instead i guess this is good
but the limits aren't really severe
enough to stop you from chowing down on
grass to get past a difficult section
of the game if there's an item that you
want to skip to quickly then put it as
the first option on your quick bar and
you'll be able to hold down on the d-pad
to skip to it instantly
this is a quality of life change added
to the other souls games and
it's a welcome one here as well they've
also added an omnidirectional rolling
while locked on which is kind of one of
those things that you would have really
felt if they decided to keep
four directional rolling like in the
original of course the ui
is also different and you know that
super modern
minimalist look is kind of jarring at
first but it did grow on me throughout
my playthrough
or i guess a better way of saying it is
i forgot about it during my playthrough
because the visuals in this game are so
overwhelmingly incredible that you don't
really want the ui to be obtrusive or
even have an interesting design at all
so i felt like it got out of the way
where it belonged uh your opinion might
differ though
so in the original demon souls a
hilarious icon would appear
when you put on the cat ring this is it
literally a cat
maybe it was a placeholder icon that
accidentally stayed in the game for the
full release who knows it became a bit
of a meme
and in the demon souls remake a lot of
people went to get the cat ring
only to discover that our cat was
nowhere to be found but in the credits
screen
after you finish the game in the screen
that shows an area from the tutorial
there's our missing boy on a flyer
pinned to a tree
have you seen this cat we miss him
another huge change in the remake are
the music scores for each boss
which have been reimagined by bill
hemsterpatz and his team
with special attention to preserving the
mood and intent
of the original game kirsan the game's
original composer has actually given her
approval of the revived soundtrack on
twitter
and that is some high praise coming from
her because i feel like
kirisan's original score is it
contributes enormously to the atmosphere
in demon souls which i maintain
personally is the best atmosphere in any
game that from software has ever made
one thing i think we can all appreciate
about the remade tracks was
how they're interwoven into the
cinematics and the gameplay
listen to this clip from the made in
australia fight
i'll probably give my full thoughts on
the music in another video
when i've taken the time to carefully
listen to all of the tracks but
i will say while playing i did like what
i heard yes
some of them have a different tone but
you know just because it's different
doesn't mean it's bad and i enjoyed
thinking about what this change in tone
meant for the lore of the fight that i
was experiencing
they've even gone back and got a lot of
the original voice actors and they've
re-recorded all the voice lines and some
of them actually have a bit of extra
dialogue as well
listen to this bit from a strava at that
end then i'm done for
i'll never make it out alive and to
match all of the effort that must have
got into getting these new narrations
are incredible facial animations as well
which
kind of look best in class and they
express real emotion here
but there's one character in particular
whose new animations
are amazing and cursed patches
so so much of this game is preserved
from the original demon souls but they
did update all of the attack animations
and they managed to do this
while preserving the cadence of the
original attacks
but without a doubt the best new
animations added to the game
are the critical hits god damn
[Music]
blue point knocked it out of the park
with these and there are unique ones for
one-handed and
two-handed backstabs and also you get a
unique animation if you manage to pull
off
a parry with a two-handed weapon as well
meaning each weapon class has four
different critical hit animations
and since there are 5 different weapon
classes that means there's
20 new animations in total plus the two
that you get from fist weapons
while these play out i'm also going to
announce my new demon souls themed disc
plate
to remake a demonic soul created in
collaboration with thiago
layman the concept for this piece was to
make a play on the word remake
while still being inspired by the world
and characters of demon souls
so what i came up with was to fuse two
powerful bosses
and remake their twisted soul so
standing in a similar arena to the tower
knight
under fire from the archers with flaming
arrows is the phalanx knight
dripping with the black goo of phalanx
and towering over the viewer
like the tower knight the actual boss
phalanx has a glowing core
which is visible within this character's
chest and head
and it's covered with that same wiry
armor and he even has a sort of
phalanx shield which we decided on way
before we realized that there was even
going to be a hoplite shield
in the game in the background there are
a few more easter eggs
there's longbow ulan the black phantom
form of phalanx who
used to attack from behind the legion's
shields and there's also two
familiar dragons gliding over the castle
the overall design
is inspired by those super retro movie
posters that had
really striking text and sort of solid
colors and because of this it looks
great in all sizes on display
with a matte or glossy finish whatever
you like this plate also chose this
design for their limited edition program
so for a limited time starting thursday
the 19th midnight at cet
you can buy a version of this print that
has been enhanced with selective gloss
finish
special ink and unique frames it
actually looks incredible i'm super
impressed but you're gonna have to act
quick if you want
this version because they're only making
200 and displayed club members will get
access to it 24 hours early
if they've bought from display
previously with the link in the
description you'll get 33
off if you're buying this display but
the more you add to your cart
the bigger your discount gets so
consider picking up
convergence the painted world or future
souls as well
i have a whole collection now which is
cool and working on this stuff is a huge
passion for me so
thank you for supporting it thank you
for watching enjoy the animations
and i'll see you next time
um
[Music]
um
um
you